going back to what you're talking about
about how
you can't like how you're just bored of
the anime archetype or the anime
character archetype what's like the last
character you would say from like any
any medium that you were just like
yes
you know
i [ __ ] with it i'm not an architect
[Laughter]
every character from squid game well
every character is
like flawed from squid game
yeah they're all pretty flawed yeah
but i would argue that's what made the
show so great right that's because
everyone sucked yeah yeah
i
why i enjoyed about squid game compared
to like every other let's say death game
is a lot of other death games is that
yeah a lot of the death games just run
on complete archetypes you know like
this person's the [ __ ] this person's
the good guy this person we did have the
[ __ ] in the good guy yeah we did we
did but we're like you would have bare
minimum right yeah but the thing is at
least i think why squid game worked is
that they gave more time to develop that
part of their characteristics rather
than them just being the archetype right
yeah i mean there were entire episodes
of squid game that didn't have any like
death game [ __ ] involved at all it was
just you know the characters getting to
know each other you know knowing about
the whole like backstory of some of the
characters well like one of my favorite
episodes of squid game is when you know
i don't know if there's going to be
spoilers but it's like halfway through
when you know they all decide to quit
squid game and they all go back to
is when you know they all decide the
vote mass vote to quit and go back to
society and then they realize how much
they
go back to
it really says a lot about society when
they decide to go back into the squid
games after how much they realize that
how much their life [ __ ] sucks right
like that episode was great because you
know only good to know about all the
characters and their backstories and
their relations to one another but it
also just like puts into a situation of
oh this world must really [ __ ] suck
to them that they have to resort to
going back right like that was great it
wasn't you know i it wasn't a perfect
show by any means
a lot of things wrong with it and i
understand why it's so popular like it's
very engaging it's got a really good
premise and the characters like you they
you know you you hate someone which is
saying more than a lot of shows can get
right
a lot of characters you really feel i
felt strongly that i disliked
and and a lot of shows like anime i
barely felt [ __ ] anything about these
[ __ ] characters yeah but that's what
i want god that's what i would argue is
that i think a character i think it
really
says a lot about society
i like heard you processing that in your
mind because you're just like i'm not
going to say it i'm not going to say i
think you said it really and then you
were just like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i swear
i'm
this ruin has this meme has ruined me
and what the [ __ ] what was i even saying
i don't even know squid game i was
saying
boring yeah yeah uh yeah so i was gonna
say that uh i think a character that you
end up absolutely [ __ ] hating is a
way better character than a character
you feel nothing towards right 100 right
and and so many people think like oh
this character sucks because i hate him
i'm like well no that makes him a good
character because you feel something
towards that character yeah yeah right
it's it's like uh it's like uh game of
thrones and joffrey like i i found it so
interesting have you seen like
interviews of the actor josh so sorry
he's like he's like such a cool guy he's
like one of the nicest guys i've ever
seen and he quit acting and he he quit
acting right any questions actually yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
acting after game of thrones i know it
just shows like i i i don't know if it
was his first role but he was definitely
like not an experienced actor right but
it just
surprise surprise you know
like a good actor makes a makes a
hateable character even more hateable
yeah and and i i i felt really sorry for
him uh hearing stories about how you
know kids or you know i say
kids watching game of thrones kids
watching again surprise but like people
actually thought that he was his
character and people thought he was like
an [ __ ] and i'm just like what that
blows my mind how people can like
actually look at an actor and think yeah
i bet leonardo the character says the n
word all the time bro and i saw him in
django he said it man bro
it's like the same people who are like
wow i can't did you know that joji is
just as shitty of a person as filthy
frank it's like
it's the same things like i can't
believe he's like that in real life you
know it's definitely not a character
discover filthy friend for the first
time
they're trying to [ __ ] cancel him
because like did you know five years ago
he was this filthy frank characters
making fun of
like mentally you know disabled people's
like yes
yes internet we did
how long ago was that because it felt
like yesterday it was like
it's about a year or two ago this is
very funny yeah because it's just yeah
you know times change and definitely
definitely something like filthy thrank
and uh filthy thanks uh transitioned to
jojo till the thrank
i'm [ __ ] listening like crazy now
says a lot about society
i've completely forgotten my point
filthy
now that i looked back at it it really
is an interesting period that filthy
frank was living in because for one my
god that [ __ ] would not fly and there's
a good reason why you quit but it is
strange how rapidly it changes yeah but
like i don't know i just i also remember
as well at the peak of uh of joji's
career as filthy frank how there were so
many kids that thought that that was
just him like yeah he was so good at
keeping up because yeah because so good
at just acting as the character and you
know any normal person who watched
filthy frank would know that of course
that was an over-exaggeration that was a
character but well i remember at the
time he just joji just didn't exist you
know i remember i remember once he uh
didn't he like make a video about him
coming out as joji and then he actually
deleted that or something yeah
yeah he made a yeah he made a vlog as
george miller who's you know his real
name yeah as like himself and how he
said that he absolutely hated his fan
base yeah like i guess the weird thing
is that is
tough to
talk about is that i guess when you're
in when you're hired to play like
joffrey right right it's not it's not
his it's not the actor didn't make this
character the actor didn't make the
story yeah i just think that's kind of
difficult to talk about with uh filthy
frank is that okay
he chose to make this character yeah
this is entirely his thing so it's like
how does that play an effect into
how much of the character do you excuse
right like i you know i i don't really
give a [ __ ] about it but it's
interesting seeing how other people talk
about it and how much they think you
know oh this is this is um this is
abhorrent you know this is him doing it
et cetera et cetera because he does have
control over the character like he makes
the creative decisions so i do wonder
how much how much valid criticism you
can give in that from that position
right right well i mean i think it's the
same
criticism you'd give to any writer or
anyone who writes a script or a
character i mean you know why why not
just cancel george rr martin you know
why not cancel uh i guess yeah i guess
quentin tarantino you know for some of
the stuff he scripts and some of the
characters i i agree but it's just it's
one of those things it's probably
quentin tarantino says the end woodless
it's weird because it's like we're in
the youtube era right yeah so it's i
feel like the rules have like kind of
changed why they they they shouldn't
yeah but i know i know i know why they i
i agree with you you know i think it's
because youtubers
seem more personable than say someone
like quentin text right i'm not saying i
that's how i think yeah but i think it's
worth discussing i i think a lot of the
people who try to cancel other people
are you know a younger generation and
you know it's it's going to take a
learning experience of when this younger
generation who are now in their teenage
years when they grow up
five ten years in the future and realize
some of the [ __ ] they're saying now are
are being are
like
are are things that can get them
cancelled as they when they're an adult
they realize
oh okay maybe society just changes as
time goes on and what's socially
acceptable what's socially acceptable
changes and you know maybe we should
give some people the benefit of the
doubt sometimes when
things happen
i guarantee you you know you go back 10
years ago to like any new grounds
comments right and you see the amount of
people throwing the r word and the f
word and the n word around and comments
like it means nothing because back then
on the internet
everyone it was just a general
understanding that yeah none of that
meant anything because it was the
internet now you look at it now and you
know if you if you wrote any kind of
comment or tweet like that it's just
insta cancel yeah yeah yeah two points
two points two points first of all why
why is it that then these why do you
think that some people would then try
and cancel someone like filthy frankrad
who's a youtuber playing a character why
do you think they were trying to cancel
him but not say someone else who's just
like playing a character i think i think
it's because now the the younger
generation who don't know about filthy
frank right they only know george as
joji who is this innocent guy who just
makes music right yeah
and you know it's to them filthy frank
is like his dark past you know it's it's
something
it
i can't believe he changed identities
online to try and hide the fact that he
did some dark [ __ ] in the past man has a
[ __ ] villain backstory
[Applause]
it's like it's like his evil upbringing
right it's like that's that's how some
people perceive her though which which
just made it so funny because i think to
a lot of these people who tried to
cancel
joji as filthy frank thought that he
changed his name to hide the filthy
frank yeah era when everyone knows
everyone who grew up with filthy frank
knows that no that's not the case he
just didn't want to keep making content
like that it didn't make him any money
because of the changing landscape of
youtube and he just wanted to focus on
music
i'll save my other question for later
but next question then following up on
that question to you guys question
question to you guys right okay so
if we had
a filthy frank now yeah that came out
now do you think it would be any
different
yeah yeah totally because you think it
would never it would never be a thing no
because
dude like but like i'm sure you've seen
enough filthy frank videos to know that
ninety percent of the [ __ ] he made right
would not fly together right but like
why is it that
we we look back at that fondly and we
look back at these videos and then like
it's because we lived through it true
true and we know that it wasn't serious
we knew that it was a caricature it was
an over exaggeration i always wonder as
well i'm like okay so
you get to get to play a character right
and you get to do this stuff i wonder
though like how much are you allowed to
do as a said character like how how
where does it stop where you're like
okay this is too much
well it's it all depends on the time and
what's except for at the time i remember
i mean back when our parents growing up
it was cool to look up to rock stars who
trashed hotel rooms did [ __ ] drugs
until they you know they were more they
were more cocaine than blood you know
and uh and you know that was that was
what was cool at the time and that was
it was what was acceptable at the time
you know it's just imagined like it's
like a tick tock of someone being like i
worked at the hotel the who stayed at
and it was like really [ __ ] up they
trashed their room and everything and
like you shouldn't support them
because i could just envision it it's
like the who is cancer being rock stars
this
you know honestly like we joke about
that but it might honestly be the case
what would happen because you don't hear
about like rock bands anymore doing [ __ ]
like that right because i feel they're
scared now that that the possibility of
that oh the the star of then is dead so
the repercussions just like they they at
the time they could get away with it
without repercussions yeah that was just
what was like accepted at the time i'm
not saying it's right but it was rock
and roll yeah it was rock and roll yeah
yeah i mean yeah obviously i mean i
don't know how some of these [ __ ]
rock stars are still alive honestly
hearing something oh yeah stories
like yeah like keith richards is like he
should have died like 50 years ago from
the amount of coke he did
but he's still playing with the rolling
stones it's like actually amazing like
he's actually like he is dear he's like
he's 100
yeah i i i love talking about all that
stuff and like again considering it
because it's just so difficult to like
get anyone to like give you a good
definitive answer of where they think
things lie i think it's because it's so
yeah it is up to interpretation and i
think it it really does depend on the
person like there's probably a lot of
people watching this podcast who have
probably watched filthy thing i think
the shit's like cringe or like two years
right you know and you know there's some
videos where i look back i'm like oh
okay yeah there were some videos where
i'm like okay that's a little too far
right but i i i think i think part of it
is just acknowledging that you know uh
society changes
and uh you know especially things that
are comedic yeah you know comedy a lot
of comedy pushes the edges pushes the
edge a lot of the times and what is
acceptable in that time period and just
because like there's their [ __ ] i found
funny 10 years ago that is very cringe
or like very like
i don't know
background animation yeah yeah exactly
but like i acknowledge that part of that
is just because the times were different
and it's not it's not that i was a bad
person you know
it's not that we were bad kids or that
you know the type people there were you
know inherently bad it was just things
what what what is acceptable changes as
time goes on as different issues
different social issues get brought up
to the limelight and you're just like
okay well now that say this social issue
is brought up i do no longer find this
one thing funny and you know that's
that's part of how society evolves yeah
i mean you know i still fondly remember
when i was growing up with new grounds
and seeing
so many new grounds animations which at
the time i thought was like the funniest
[ __ ] on the planet like the first time i
watched ultimate showdown of ultimate
destiny i thought that was the funniest
[ __ ] i've ever seen in my life and i
watch it now and i'm like that's cute
it's like i can't laugh at it i can
reminisce about it but i can't like
throw my head back and laughter at it
anymore because it's just something that
yeah it's just as you said it's just
completely changed with not just how i
perceive comedy but just how
society
we stop saying
you know how the world perceives comedy
or like the the barrier for comedy right
yeah